all right beautiful
beautiful oh where'd you grow up where
are you from i'm kingston jamaica
you're from jamaica yes oh wow and you
you came to the u.s what five years old
five years old at five and tell me about
your childhood you had both your parents
yes how was life with with you folks
um different my mom it was great
and my father turned out to be a pastor
but
he fell by the wayside maybe somewhere
along the way
i was eight years old i don't know what
happened
but the people stayed at my head they
put a curse on my family
and my dad ended up molesting me from
about eight years old to
um i was about 13. oh my god
and my mom leave him and we end up with
my stepfather
so we came to the united states they
gave us clearance to come to the united
states
and we moved to new jersey
she wasn't working out there so we moved
to dayton ohio
from that point i was maybe
14. we had our handicapped sisters so i
stayed home most of the time
do home studies and help my mother
she met a new gentleman things went from
there
um i was always kind of a
good but bad kid like i told you i'm
gifted i have different gifts
and it's really weird to have them um
people say it's kind of like esp if you
go
yes or you know i don't know how i
still to this day can't explain it but i
see things i feel things
and i think it's because of my
background and my heritage
um you'll sense things that other people
won't oh yeah
it's scary though um
it caused my mom to kind of pull away
from me she dealt with the other kids
more than me
so i got standoffish pretty much shy
i fought a lot in school nobody liked me
seems different now but nobody really
liked me
i started prostituting i hid it from my
mom
i started having sex had my first baby
in high school
i still graduated
then my handicapped sister died from
pneumonia
and ken and my mother lost it a little
bit she didn't care about us
she'd spank us hate us beat us she
didn't she just was
done um
i guess as you can see as i get older i
had to get a job
i had to do whatever it took to survive
and help my mother survive
and me and my brother are the only two
siblings left now
every last one of us are god father
mother both sisters it's just me and my
baby rather now
i have six beautiful kids and two
grandbabies
but they're still distance right now who
are they with
my two younger ones are with the my kids
father's family
my older ones are all older yeah so i
don't have
too much worry about them but they worry
about me did you raise the older ones
yes for the most part can you still talk
to her
oh definitely i love my kids that's my
new
release to life so i'm still homeless to
this day
i'm still prostituting but you've had
jobs oh
wonderful jobs you've had careers yes i
worked in real estate
um i actually was a manager so one of
the largest um it's called the metro car
express
it's one of the largest car wash
exchanges there and i was the manager to
one in um san fernando valley
so kind of got fired because everybody
got fired
our bus was stealing money and they
found out about it
and um they kind of got rid of his whole
crew everyone he hired
they got rid of us all so
so you went back to the streets quickly
because i was staying with him and his
family and there were hispanic people
and without a job you can't live with
them they don't want you there
so they put us all up yeah
um i'm not really sure
um i've worked with the police
department actually before
you too yeah it's weird um i actually
helped
solve a car crash case on
74th and um i believe it's um grand
a 13 year old boy was um ran over they
couldn't find the person
the family was pressing the police
department very hard
i covered that i found the car
i don't know how just don't ask me it
just all worked out
you use your your empathic skills
it worked um the family they gave me a
thousand dollars
at the time they gave me what they could
so i was a blessing um
[Music]
i really don't know what to say this is
my first time ever doing this or even
telling people this so it's kind of
weird and i don't i'm like scared to
even be telling people this i don't want
to open people like
oh she does this but um they kind of do
it anyways
a lot of people flock to me i don't know
if it's others like me
but we all have the same sense it's
really weird but it's fun to be around
people who even
are interested you could say
um i have a tent they set my chain on
fire
with me in it it's getting really ugly
out there
so you're homeless oh yeah definitely
homeless
um i'm working with the county right now
to get into the pilot program
i don't know if people know about it but
it's a decent program um
they provide vouchers for motel rooms
but they have a certain time frame
so that time frame runs out you're just
back on the streets until they can
get you situated with housing so
um you'd have to rely on church or
different agencies for showers clothes
and different things like that
i try to just work with any and
everybody like down here in downtown
they've got a lot of um businesses
you can sweep fold clothes and there's
things you can do
so i apply myself in different ways so
that i can stay productive
because it's really bad out here and
there's a lot of sickness yeah and i
don't want it
so so working the streets as a
prostitute now you
you're working on your own yes no camp
yes no pam
and uh my kids are my pimps i have to
try to make sure i send them some type
of money
um i'm not i just even though my
daughter tells me mom
worry about yourself you're outside in
the streets worry about yourself i can't
do it
i've got to do something 50 bucks
whatever i can to send to them
she tries to send it back we have this
thing
but i have beautiful children so yeah
being a prostitute out here is hard
i've been raped five times or more
um i just had a recent incident i
believe i was telling you about it
i was pulled out of a car and i was held
down
and they were taking a torch to the side
of my body
here and i mean i could show you burn
marks
but they were burning me they had
nonsense on a date
it was not even in their mind they were
there to
flick fame and they did their job
i only got away because the lady at the
um church putting on the corner
some reason heard me yelling she came
out
she got me away from him took off
it's hard uh nothing's the same out here
at all does it get you down huh you must
get depressed
by doing this right i do because it's
not something that i choose to do it's
not something that i like
i'm not very promiscuous though so
um to do it it's
i can't say it's disgusting because the
natural ordinance have sex
to me it just kind of throws me in a
different frame of mind because it puts
me back with my
when i was being raped all molested by
my father
and then raped so then to continue to do
this right now and kind of
i'm leery i don't know who to deal with
when to deal with them i try to read
people before i deal with them
to kind of see where their mindset is
sometimes we're still wrong
you know without my face busted open
here i've still got wires in my jaw
um there's some real tricky pimps out
here now
they'll come at you as a date or
whatever just to get you in the car
when you're in the car they'll take you
all your money they're going to rob you
and they're going to tell you you have
one or two options you're going to work
for me
you're going to get me money or you're
going to get texts every time
we see you on the street and they do
that
um it's a blessing to find different
people who
actually pull you in we don't get that
very often and being women out here
it's like guys are like 100 to one of us
and they're gonna press you they're
gonna beat you up
they're gonna find a way to get you on
your own they're taking advantage of our
vulnerability to the fullest
and nobody's saying anything to them so
they feel they can get away with it
there's no time i mean i'm not a police
type person but
there's just nothing there they're like
all in the cloud
moving around they just drive
and because they mention the sickness
thing everyone's all afraid
so it's like the police doesn't even
want to come near anybody
well what if we really need help where
are you guys
oh it's that one there is go guy
it's not cool like literally they burnt
my tan tap if i took this hair piece off
you'd see my hair was on fire
i mean i could show you some really
crazy crap you'd be like what the
[ __ ] are you guys outside for you know
so excuse me for cussing but
yeah i was burned it's not a good
feeling
i'm not happy now that i met our friend
capone
i get to sleep in his car every now and
again for safety
he goes in he has people he can go
inside with so i utilize the car
any means i can to get safe i use it
um the churches aren't open to us
anymore so that's a no no
you can get a shower excuse me some food
that's about it are drugs a part of your
life
drug programs um do you use
no that's the problem with me and
they're testing people now on the way in
so if you're not dirty they don't want
you i found a transitional couple
transitional homes
um susan burton it's called a new way of
life
um she accepts anybody but she's so full
like every one of her houses and she's
got 16.
and they're all full so um
if i could find more places like hers
i'd be
okay do you feel like what happened to
you and your father when you were eight
years old
kind of led the like opened the door for
you to do it when you were younger
and then again now when you got more
desperate i do
and it's not a good feeling sometimes
when i'm doing it i feel dirty
and then if anybody approaches me that
looks like my dad i'm just freaked out
i feel like i'm being haunted like i
literally freak out i'm like like
where'd you come from i feel like either
he's trying to apologize to me
but then these people are coming at me
asking him for the same thing he took
for me
so i'm just like this is really weird
like you know and i'm just like no i
won't do it
i'm just like i can't i don't want to
deal with anybody
you know if i find someone that looks
like him i shell off
big time that hurt me more than anything
because my dad was my best friend
like literally i was riding my dad's
shoulders we'd sing we dance with
music you know that was my best friend
so everything else was
like wow you know and they're robbing us
blind out here you can't
there's just nothing we're just getting
robbed blind
you know and
there's no one that cares and like
i can sing i can dance
i have other qualities but at 43 years
old
most people look at me like i'm a little
kid where that comes from i have no clue
but most people view me as a child i get
that
everywhere i don't know where that comes
from
i know i look pretty young for my age i
get it
um tomorrow's my birthday and um
i have no clue what i'm gonna do happy
birthday thank you
um you have any friends no
kaboom and i met him on a humbug
home what is humbug he almost ran me
over
and he what is humbug like just on the
fluke
like just oh i see yeah he um almost ran
me over
and um he's felt bad ever since like
every time he sees me he's like
uh do you need your food um can i get
you and i'm just like you don't have to
do that
but now we kind of got a little
friendship thing where like i said i
could sleep in the car
he goes in the house with whoever you
know he has family out here i don't
so for him to even integrate me into his
family like the girl he was with today
is his sister
i got to meet her she let me sleep on
her um floor last night
so i got to sleep inside a house finally
after almost about seven months
so yeah i have to take a real bath
you know what i mean those things you
cherish
after you haven't had him for a while
you get him again he cheers him
what's the most important lesson you've
learned from your the rough
the rough life you've had oh
to temper my mouth because
i have a real live jamaican attitude
and we're pop off real fast type people
bear we don't think no crap so
for me to deal with how these american
people do
to steal my mouth i have to observe
every situation
i cannot allow anything i'm getting
goosebumps
i can't allow anything to get me to that
point
because i'll probably die because i'm
really
hot-headed so like this lady's telling
your name
like those are the stuff like no one has
no consideration
there's no respect there's no boundaries
no more i feel like we're in sodom and
gomorrah right now
it's just sex drugs killing
whoever get you know may the best
growler guy
stand up you know like it's come on i
feel like i'm in a gladiator movie right
now it's like non-stop like you said
you've got one on this and one on this
and you're like guys dude breathe
ask me can you help clean the studio i
mean
integrate bring something else out of
your
self there's nothing there nobody gets
it
it's like is there anything that you
guys see besides green
do you don't baby it's really sad
something is green and if you got it
you're cool if you don't
hey i like you you get what i'm saying
and you really can see that
out here right in front of us yeah it's
crazy
all right beautiful well thank you so
much for sharing your story thank you
and good luck with where you
go thank you very much i'm glad i'm glad
to come get off the street
yes sir thank you thank you
you